[inaudible]
organic is not a matter of belief.
Organic is codified,
regulated and it's definition is
established by the Department of
Agriculture.
So in the United States,
organic means vegetable crops that are
produced under conditions in which there
is no fertilizers,
no artificial pesticides,
and they're not genetically modified
irradiated or fertilized with sewage
sludge.
Very clear definition.
Animals must be fed organic feed,
they must be allowed access to the
outdoors.
Um,
and there are some other rules that
define that.
And in order to,
for a company to get a certified organic
seal on their product,
they must follow those rules and be
inspected to make sure they follow those
rules.
And almost everybody that I know who was
involved in the organic industry says
the rules are followed.
There's very little cheating.
Um,
and that in fact the system is pretty
tight in following the rules.
The big question is whether those rules
make any sense or not and whether
they're good enough,
strong enough and meaningful enough with
the most obvious loophole being the one
about animals having access to the
outdoors.
The rule doesn't say they have to be
The rule just says they have to have
access to.
That's a loophole.